canadian forces have been leading a nato
mission in latvia for almost five years
but it's more clear than ever how
perilous and important that mission may
be the stakes are magnified in latvia
bordering a country that is not only
waging war but has become more
unpredictable a bunch of assumptions
about how russia how putin in particular
might behave
over the last couple of years are being
upended basically on every day latvia is
not just russia's neighbor like ukraine
latvia and the baltic countries of
estonia and lithuania were once members
of the soviet union ruled by moscow
about a quarter of the population of
latvia is russian by background and like
ukraine latvia also borders belarus
russia's staunch military partner
what is going to happen to us if ukraine
is surrendered easily says this latvian
resident
we used to be part of the ussr this
woman says she feels the threat it's why
canada is sending more troops to latvia
460 armed forces personnel starting this
month with artillery guns the frigate
hmcs halifax and an aurora surveillance
aircraft are also being sent nato's
mission in the baltics is deterrence
russia respects strength and that's what
nato is trying to demonstrate in their
eastern flank countries like latvia
latvia is convinced that its membership
in nato is what will hold russia at bay
the taser our allies starting from
canadians and ending with other
europeans are with us is a good signal
that
putin don't mess with us it's a a
measured response on part of canada to
in terms of the number of troops we're
sending but it's a meaningful one to go
and enhance the deployment that we
already have there while latvia enjoys
nato protection who can be sure of
vladimir putin's next move these days he
has surprised us we have everyone has
said we don't believe he will do this
and he has
though we have to be on guard
and being on guard is the canadian
mission in latvia eric sorensen global
news toronto